[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
対象ではなく a 創造のストーリーを変化の波をプレ付リーダーシップで
乗り越えよう
それが今日の私のへメッセージです
今年はこのなで本当にたくさん多くの変化ということがあったんじゃないかなと思い
ます
例年通り同じことをやろうと思ってもなかなか同じようにいかないということはみな
さんの日常の中にもたくさんあったんじゃないかと思っています
で特にリーダーとかの役割やっている人たちは厳しい判断ということを日々
してきたんじゃないかなと思います
そういった判断をしていくときにですね我々は常に対処なのかもしくは
創造なのかまあこの2つの選択ということを
様られていたんじゃないかなと思います
対処のストーリーというのは昨年通りやってることっていうのは変えずにですね
まあ何とかこの場後ろ5まあそういうような考え方で
一方で創造のストーリーというのはせっかくこういう機会なんだから新しいことに挑戦
しよう
まあそういう考え方というのがまあ想像のストーリーという風に言うことができます
では私としてはですねまあこういうような機械でたくさん製薬というのはあるんです
けれども
その制約ということをアルシュ遊びに変えて新しいことを作り出すんだ
まあそういう想像のストーリーを作りだということが大事なんじゃないかということを
今日みなさんにお伝えしたい
いうふうに思っています
でまあこういうことを言うのはですねマルシュ簡単なんですけれども
実際やるのは本当にすごく大変なんだということはですね
は私自身も非常にですねまあ同じような思いをして
まあ言っている部分があります
例えばこの写真へ見ていただきたいんですけれども
まあこれはですね私が行っているリーダーシップ巨5プログラムの一つのば年になり
ます
私は立教大学の経営学部でへリーダーシップ教育の主査ということをしています
でその主査の役割というのはですね入ってきた新入生たち
まあそれと先輩たちを合わせた約600名の人達を対象にですね
インタラクティブに実践的な教育プログラムを
まあやるということがですねあの私のミッションなんですけれども
当然ですね今年これをそのままやるというのはたいへんだったわけです
まあこうやって今見るとですね非常に密な写真だなというふうに思うかもしれません
ってこうやって一度にあのに学生たちが集まるだけじゃなくて
まぁ実際はクライアントになる企業の方とですね
まあ一緒にあの子らべーションをしたりですとかまたさらには
5600人で炭素するみたいな事っていうのも実はやっていたわけです
まあこれは組織の一体感を高めるということだったり
この学部に来て良かったということを感じてもらうためにやっていたしたわけです
てこういうことですね4月に新入生たちと一緒にやっていくことでこの学部でよかった
この学部に来て良かった
リーダーシップを身に付けるとこんな感じなのかということだったり
まあ本気で学ぶことっていうのがかっこいいことなんだまあこういうことですね
私たちをメッセージとして伝えたいと思って毎年こういうことをやって
きているわけなんですけれども今年これをそのままできるのかという風に考えたら
まあできないですよね
でそんな中で僕たちはどうしたらいいのかまあこういうところで私も同じように対処な
のか想像なのか言うところの選択に迫られたわけです
て実際こういうプログラムを作る時のまあ準備というのはですね1月ぐらいからずっと
やっていくわけなんですけれども
まあその時に私たちに起こっていた事ってどういうことかっていうのですね
端的に表現するとまあ堅守と中止と塩キー
まあこの中でどうするのかということを迫られて言いました
まあどういうことかと言いますとまあ1月配っていうのはですね
本来は大学に来てグループワークをしながら
このプログラムをどうやって作っていこうかということを一から考えていくわけなん
ですけれどもそうした大学の中で集まってミーティングするということは禁止だよ
いう風になって集まれなく
でまた本来はですね教職員だったり学生スタッフだったり一緒になって勝っ宿にいって
まぁどういうふうにしようかということを考えたりするんですけれどもそれが中止に
なったり
てまた本来4月の頭にある先ほどのプログラムみたいのもあるんですけれどもそれが
雑誌月の後半になるよう
5月になるよいうような形でどんどん
延期になっていたりそしてその都度私たちはプログラムを作り直したり
いうことをやっていたんですけれどもやっぱり交差日々の中でですね
本当にできるのかなということだったりせっかく作ったのにまた
作り直したよみたいな感じで我々のモチベーションというのはものすごく下がっていっ
たわけですね
やっぱりそういうことを考えていると最初の対象になるか想像なのかって考えた時に
かっこよく想像っていうふうに言いたいんですけれども
今年は仕方がないからガイダンスだけにしようからみたいな気持ちというのもここの中
でどこが出てくるわけです
でこの中でどうしようということはですね私もまあ正直
1日以降で込みながら考えました
ただやっぱりそのときにじゃあ自分が一番ワクワクすることって何なのかなということ
を
まあ探していくときにぱっと思いつくことがあったんですね
その時に僕が思いついた事っていうのがせっかくなんだったら世界一のオンライン
リーダーしプログラムを作る機会にしたらいいんじゃないか
まあこういうふうに僕の中でパッとファイルやが思いついたんです
でこれはまあ本当になぜと言われたわからないですけど
パッと出てきたことなんですけれどもまあこのコロナの状況のなかでこういう
プログラムができない厳しい状況だということはまあ自分たちだけではなくてですね
まぁ世界中の教育館大学というところが
まあ直面している
いう大きな問題なんじゃないかなと思っ
でその時に我々がですねインタラクティブでしかも面白くて本当に学習者の学びになる
ようなそういうプログラムを押し作り出すことができたんだったらそれは胸を張って
世界一のオンラインリーダーシッププログラムだというふうに言えるんじゃないかなと
いうふうにふと思った時に
ですね他結構ワクワクしてきたんですね
よしこれだったら自分の気持ちというのは保てる
一生懸命できるんじゃないかというふうに思ったんです
でただこれを僕だけが思っていてもチームとしてはこれに向かってはいけません
いきなりこんな事を言ってですねみんなが減って思ったらどうしようっていうことも
正直考えました
だけどまぁそれを信じてですね
3月27日だったと思うんですけれども学生スタッフたちの兄ティングの中で最初は
ですね
正直にその時に思っている不安だったりだとか
不満ということというのを共有しました
対面でやりたかったよねっ
一泊二日でみんなで最高の舞台というのを作りたかった
それは僕自身もそういうふうに思っていたところもありますのでそういう思いを共有し
た後にですねまぁでも
僕はせっかくやるんだったら世界一のオンラインリーダーシッププログラムを作りたい
んだということを学生たちに伝えました
そしたらですね学生たちももちろん半信半疑だと尾部
あると思うんですけれどもそれだったら楽しそうだというような形でよしみんなでこの
機会を挑戦してみよう
まあそういうような思いいうことをチームで共有することができました
そこからですねもうあとはこれをどうやってやればいいかそれだけを考えればいいと
いうことで
まあそれだけって言ってももちろんすごく大変でした
ズームもですねズームの編を21個立ててそして更にそこで youtube live
を連携して
そんな仕組みを作ったらただオンラインに
で聞いてるだけじゃなくてアクティブなことできるんじゃないか
偉大な感じで新しい仕組みを考えたり
ダンスということをオンラインで実現するためにはどうしたらいいんだろう
やっぱりこうやってずれちゃったりするんですよね我々の動きっていうのはす
ん
なのでええ
その中でどうしたらいいかということっていうのはやっぱり私たち自身も悩みました
でただまぁそんな中でですね実際どういうふうにやろうということを必死に考えた結果
実際にオンラインで先ほどのようなプログラムということを実現することができました
例えばこのような形で実際にビジネスプランを作って発表するみたいな事っていうのも
できましたし
さっきのダンスみたいなことに関しても小さく
ハートを小分けすることでですね
ちっちゃく振りをやって
細かく撮った動画をつなげることで全体の一体感を作り出す
まぁこんなようなことというのがをすることでですね
まあ対面でやっている時に近いようなまあそういうような
ローバーを作ることができました
まあ終わった瞬間というのは本当にですねまぁ涙とこみ上げてくる
思いでした
それだけやっぱり割とへ我々が一生懸命やっていたところが伝わったのか
a
アンケートの結果いうのも手ですねまあこれは本当に自分自身もびっくりしたんです
けれども
対面で1泊2日で行っているプログラム呼びもですね
高い評価いうことを得ることができました
それは我々がですねまあこういう状況の中で必死になってやっている姿というところが
伝わったのかなというふうに思っています
で改めてですねじゃあ対処のではなくて創造のストーリーにするために何が必要なのか
ということをもう1回考えていきたいんですけれども
まず1つは現実的な楽観主義
まあこういう考え方というのが大事なんじゃないかなと思っています
まあ単に楽観ということではなくてですねやっぱり正直心配なことだったり不安な
ことっていうのはなんか皆さんありますよ僕自身もありました
でそういう思いをですねまずちゃんと共有する
そしてそこからワクワクすることでは何なんだろうということを考え
まあこういうステップっていうのはすごく大事なんだろうなというふうに思います
でじゃあどうやってこういう中でワクワクするのか
難しいんじゃないなというふうに思うかもしれないんですけれども
そこで出てくるもう一つこのプレゼンテーションの中で大事なキーワードというのが
遊びというキーワードです
このなでまぁ本当に制約だらけの状況だと思うんですけれども
まあこの制約ってなんとなく皆さんネガティブなイメージがあったり遊びというと自由
っていうイメージをみなさん思われたりすると思う
思うんですけど実は遊びと制約ということというのは密接に結びついていてその制約と
いうことというのは楽しさを生み出す
元だったり
するんです
たとえばここにゴミ箱があります
私がですね何かゴミを拾ってこのボイパ国のところまで行ってゴミを捨てる
これは本当にどこに遊びの要素があるのかわからない
まぁたん練る作業かもしれません
ただ僕がですねここに者何かしら線を引いて
この線にから先に行かずにですねこれを
コーンと投げて
音箱に捨てる
まあこういうことをした瞬間にゴミを捨てるって言う行為っていうのはある種
遊びに切り替わるわけです
じゃあは行が遊びにカール瞬間ってなんだったのかって言うとですね
ここから先に行かないという風に自分で決めた制約というのが楽しさということという
のを生み出しているわけです
私の好きなあの言葉なんですけれどもでこれを端的に先ほどのことというのを表現した
言葉に
ばゲームをプレイするっていうのは取り組む必要のない障壁を自発的に来ようとする
取り組みであっていうような言葉があります
まあこれらの中でですねいろいろやらなきゃいけないハードルというのはたくさんある
のかもしれないんですけれども
そのハードルということを自分の中でもう1回
設定し直すみたいなことすることでもしかしたらこうワクワクの要素ということを
取り入れられるんじゃないかなと思います
例えば先ほどの私の挑戦世界一のオンラインリーダーシッププログラムを作るんだと
いう話をしましたけれども
別に世界一のオンラインリーダーしプログラムにこのだからしなきゃいけなかったわけ
ではないんですよね
それは自分の中で色々制約の中で新しい
自発的に乗り越えようというような制約
壁ということを設定し直してみたんですね
そしたら僕の中の気持ちとしても
はワクワクしてきましたしそのワクワクする気持ちっていうことがチームのメンバー
たちに伝わっていってまぁこういう大きな成果ということを得ることができたんじゃ
ないかなというふうに思うわけです
まあこういうようなですねアルシュ製薬ということを力に変えて楽しみながら
バリュー巻き込んでいくっていうことがタイトルに入れていた私にとっての真プレイ
フルなリーダーシップっていうふうに言えるんじゃないかなと思っています
最後にもう一度まとめです
対象でなく創造のストーリーよということで本当にたくさんいろんな
今もですね制約だらけの中で生活をしなきゃいけないところっていうのはあると思うん
ですけれども
その制約をですね自分なりにもう一度捉え直して自分で飛び越えてみたいというような
障壁に置き換えた時にですね
実は強いられた
作業ではなくてですねわくわくするような遊びの感覚ということが得られるんじゃない
かと思います
そしてそういうワクワク感というのは必ず周りのメンバーたちに伝わってそれだったら
一緒にやろう
いうような創造のストーリーに繋がっていくんじゃないかなと思います
まだまだ変化たくさんあるんですけれども皆さんと一緒にプレイフルなリーダーシップ
で乗り越えていきたいなというふうに思っています
私のプレゼンテーションは以上ですありがとうございました